la génération numérique c'est elle
collégiens lycéens ses enfants
d'internet passe un peu plus d'une heure
par jour sur facebook
ça permet de retrouver les gens qu'on
connaît ça de rester en contact avec eux
un peu partout dans le monde mais je
pense aussi que c'est dangereux parce
que n'importe qui peut avoir notre nom
et n'importe qui peut nous a ajouté et
ça va au notre adresse que ça parce que
maintenant maintenant mais on habitait
tout ça dans quel lycée on est donc je
pense que ça a des côtés positifs et des
côtés négatifs
moi je pense qu'il y avait vraiment une
virtual connect sur facebook on rentre
chez soi et puis on parle avec ses amis
on regarde des photos de ses amis mais
virtuellement rien de tout cas pas il ya
plus de contacts physiques n'a plus de
contacts humains l'utilisation est
abusive pour beaucoup de personnes mais
l'idée fondamentale du réseau est quand
même intéressante et je pense que c'est
juste au niveau de l'utilisation et des
utilisateurs qui a des choses à corriger
en quelques années facebook est devenu
une star incontournable chez les jeunes
92% des 15 17 ans un compte 80 % des 13
15 ans
mais c'est surtout chez les plus jeunes
d'entre eux que cela peut surprendre
64 % ont un profil sur facebook
si certains parents s'interrogent sur
les dérives des réseaux sociaux les
professionnels de l'enfance ne
reconnaissent pas le danger
on a utilisé la même réflexion on a eu
les mêmes interrogations les mêmes
inquiétudes
avec le portable est maintenant plus
personne n'ose poser une question sur le
portable alors le pc le portable s'est
transformé en véritable outil magique
puisque on peut tout faire sur un
portable y compris utiliser facebook
mais sur facebook certains souffrent
d'une mauvaise réputation
photo vidéo un engrenage parfois
difficiles à stopper 50 % des 13 15 ans
ne protège pas à leurs informations
personnelles
chez les plus jeunes d'entre eux cet
enfant sur dix s'expose inconsciemment
sur les réseaux sociaux
les photos qui sont des photos qui
peuvent être quasi pornographique qui a
transmis par par portable happy slapping
oui il ya un risque
oui il peut y avoir une dérive
mais il faut faire très très attention à
ne pas accabler l'outil en tant que tel
parce que l'outil l'outil les
responsables bien entendu mais celui qui
est responsable l'outil ce sujet le
moulin génération numérique
la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui est peut-être
tout simplement en phase avec
l'évolution d'une société et
probablement même plus responsable que
beaucoup de le croire